today i'm going to show you the best way
to lose
belly fat now i haven't done
a video on belly fat in a while i've
done a lot of them and i will put some
links down below if you haven't seen
them but i wanted to touch on some new
information and give you a
deeper understanding of what's going on
because
any time
you try to solve a problem and it
doesn't solve realize that you may be
solving the wrong problem and this is
very evident in the area of weight loss
since it has like a 98
failure rate when attempting to lose
weight now you can try counting your
calories and lowering your calories or
exercising more and seeing how that
works for you but there's a much better
approach
and i am going to be including exercise
in this video as well because it is
important it's not the most significant
thing but it is important i'm going to
show you about five different exercises
that are
really helpful but
in the big scheme of things you're
really only looking at about 15 of your
results will come from exercise
when i go to the gym and i watch people
week after week
trying to exercise their belly fat off
and you just you don't see any change
and there's a reason for that
to understand that reason i'm going to
do a little tiny deep dive into both
metformin which is a medication they use
for diabetes
and
tell you why it were also works for
weight loss now i'm not recommending it
but it's important to understand why it
works okay and i will cover that in a
second
and then also the other procedure called
gastric bypass which also helps you lose
weight but not
from the reason you might think not from
just reducing calories
it works for another reason so
understanding both of these things in
relationship to weight loss um it will
validate
um what i've been saying for a very long
time now most people know this but if
you have belly fat
what's going on is you have liver fat
and you're getting this
spill off of this fat from your liver
into the abdominal cavity okay so if you
look down and you can't seem to see your
shoes
we know you have a fatty liver so it's
very important to target the real
problem of fatty liver as well as what
causes the fatty liver and most people
would agree that that would be too much
insulin okay so it's the excess amount
of insulin if you have too much insulin
the body stores fat in the liver and
then it spills off into the abdominal
area that's called visceral fat and if
you reduce your insulin
which is the fat storing hormone
that is the mechanism that helps you
tap into fat and burn fat especially in
your midsection as well as in your liver
so the real problem is not just that you
are overweight it's that you have too
much insulin and yes you need to lower
your carbs but there's some other things
you need to understand as well now let's
first talk about metformin it's a
medication
that is used in diabetes but in other
conditions as well like they use it in
pcos polycystic ovarian syndrome because
it helps women with that condition so
really what it's doing it's lowering
insulin so really why they use it in
pcos is that
the high levels of androgens which is
causing the hair loss the facial hair
the deeper voice
is coming from an increase of insulin
and so metformin lowers insulin also
metformin is very effective for weight
loss why because it helps you lower
insulin now i'm definitely not
recommending metformin i'm also going to
say if you are on metformin i'm not
telling you to come up with metformin
too but just want to help you understand
why it works so metformin uh was
originally derived from an herb called
goatsru and they found certain
properties
that
helped increase insulin
sensitivity so metformin
helps you to get rid of insulin
resistance
so insulin resistance occurs because
there's too much insulin right so
metformin works
to overcome that and it just makes your
cells
more receptive to insulin and so your
body can produce less but the thing is
and this is might be new information for
you
metformin
stops this production
of glucose being made from your liver
when you have insulin resistance
as in a pre-diabetic or diabetic
or even neither of those you just have
insulin resistance which the majority of
the population has
your liver is making too much glucose
and that's called
gluconeogenesis neo which means new
genesis means the creation of and then
gluco glucose so just making too much
sugar and as a side note when some
people start the ketogenic diet and they
start waking up in the morning and
having this thing called the dawn
phenomena where they have high blood
glucose that is because of the liver
making too much glucose out of
fat
out of
protein
out of ketones
so anytime your body has insulin
resistance
it's going to be making more glucose in
the liver and i mean think about this
here you are
you cut down your carbs but you still
can't lose weight
why because your body is making glucose
it's not even coming from your diet your
body is making it from
fat a lot of people don't know that
so metformin helps
that condition it stops the liver from
making glucose
but the problem with metformin it has
side effects it even comes with a black
box warning called lactic acidosis
because
that could actually kill you and it
depletes your b1 and your b12 what you
might not realize is there's other herbs
like berberine for example
that can create effects almost identical
to metformin so why would you want to
take metformin when there's a natural
alternative so the way metformin works
is it reduces the production of glucose
in your liver okay so that's it's gonna
help you lose weight right there
because glucose turns into
fat through the help of insulin but
metformin also reduces fat in your liver
okay so
anything that reduces insulin and gets
rid of fat off the liver is going to
help you get rid of your belly so it
does both of those actions so the fact
that metformin works for weight loss and
belly fat and even diabetes validates
what i've been saying forever you must
focus on the reduction of insulin if you
want to be successful with your belly
fat now let's shift gears to gastric
bypass
you might initially think that if you
reduce the size of your stomach and
bypass some of your small intestine that
you're going to eat less and then lose
weight because of the lower amount of
calories
but in reality there's something else
going on there's a certain hormone okay
um which i'll just tell you it's gip
that increases insulin in the small
intestine and when you do a gastric
bypass you
pretty much destroy that hormone so it's
no longer going to be active anymore so
when you get gastric bypass what's
happening is you're dramatically
dropping insulin this is why
it does work for diabetes type two this
is why people do lose weight but at the
expense of this surgical procedure which
i'm not recommending because honestly i
don't think you need to go that far you
just have to understand that there's a
hormone in your small intestine called
gip that increases insulin every time
you eat okay it doesn't matter what you
eat so if you eat a meal it's going to
increase insulin so the two things
that will increase insulin is both
carbohydrates or glucose or sugar
and
frequent eating okay so this also
validates the whole concept of
intermittent fasting you want to eat
less it's not about the reduction of
calories it's about eating less
frequently so intermittent fasting
essential
powerful and lowering insulin getting to
the core of why you have belly fat as
well as getting rid of fat in your liver
so i hope that gives you some
understanding of why it's so important
to focus on the real problem
insulin to
help you extract fat off the liver as
well as eventually have a flat stomach
so here's what you need to do number one
go on a low carb diet
number two do intermittent fasting
both of those actions are the most
powerful things and within 14 days you
can reduce up to 50 of your fat
off your liver which is going to
usually show up in your midsection as
well number three
there's some really important core
exercises that i'm going to get to at
the end of this i'm going to walk you
through them and that's going to help as
well so why does core exercises help you
lose weight um not to
melt off off your belly but just to
strengthen the muscles as well as it
helps lower insulin okay so it helps get
rid of insulin resistance that's why you
see the results it's not about just
using up the calories like most people
think all right number four fiber as in
consuming enough greens
helps you in different ways
number one the magnesium and the
potassium
both help with insulin resistance it
makes insulin more sensitive
plus the fiber that is consumed by your
microbes
turns into something called small chain
fatty acids
um one being butyrate which then makes
insulin more sensitive so it helps get
rid of insulin resistance indirectly and
so those little microbes that you have
help you lose weight all right number
five
you want
something that can mimic metformin like
berberine
great great powerful herb that does a
lot but one thing it can do it can help
make insulin more sensitive next one is
apple cider vinegar you take a
tablespoon in your water and you do like
two or three of these
drinks a day you can put lemon as well
that will help but apple cider vinegar
makes insulin more sensitive thereby
reducing the amount of insulin all right
number seven you must lower your stress
level stress activates cortisol cortisol
makes you live on sugar that increases
insulin so stress is very similar to
eating
candy
as far as what it does to glucose and
insulin i have a ton of videos on this
but you really need to
go through life with a very relaxed
state of mind a relaxed attitude
you don't want to be so serious and
there's just a ton of information that
i've shared
on that topic all right number eight
your sleep
you're not going to be able to lose your
belly if you cannot sleep and you need a
high quality sleep at least seven maybe
eight hours and if you have trouble with
that i put some links down below now
we're going to go right into these
exercises all right in this first
exercise
which is really good for beginners
you're going to be doing toe touches but
not standing you're going to be
sitting down with your feet going up and
you're going to touch your toes so this
is what you do line your back with your
feet raised up and your legs about 90
degrees okay now this might not
necessarily be for beginners um but for
most people it should be doable so in
this exercise you're going to engage
your lower abdominals as you lift your
upper body off the mat reach your hands
toward your toes pausing for one to two
seconds at the top then slowly lower
back down i would recommend doing one to
three sets of about 12 to 18 repetitions
every other day this is a great exercise
for your core all right the next
exercise is called bicycle crunches now
for this exercise make sure you rotate
your core to avoid pulling your hips or
straining your neck then you're going to
stabilize your lower back to the floor
and then draw your shoulders away from
your ears so this is how to do it just
line your back with your knees and your
heels flat on the floor interlace your
fingers
at the base of your skull then you're
going to come into a starting position
by engaging your core lifting your upper
body from the floor and raising your
knees so they're directly above your
hips now on the exhale
twist your torso as you bring your right
elbow and your left knee towards each
other at the same time straighten and
extend your right leg hold this position
for a one to two count before inhaling
to the starting position
then do the opposite side this is one
repetition so you're going to do two to
three sets
of eight to 18 repetitions depending on
where your fitness level is all right
number three burpees these are these are
pretty tough now these burpees are a
very explosive exercise that will really
activate your abdominal muscles so the
first thing is to stand
uh with your feet shoulder width apart
squat down and place your palms in front
of you on the floor directly under your
shoulders now jump your legs back to
come into a push-up position do one
push-up and then jump your feet back to
the starting position raise your arms
overhead as you explosively jump upon
landing lower back down to the squat
position you want to do between six to
10 sets
of 12 to 25 repetitions now
realize you got to work up to this
because
it's going to take some time to get used
to this exercise it's pretty intense all
right number four
the boat pose this exercise will really
build your abs and spinal muscles all
right this is how you're going to do it
from a seated position lean back on your
buttocks and tailbone raise your legs
into the air and form a v-shape extend
your arms in front so they're parallel
to the floor now you're going to hold
that position for about one minute
and repeat this two to three times
number five
the forward plank holding a plank
position takes a lot of strength and
endurance and it's going to hit your abs
your back and your core the plank is one
of the best exercises for core
conditioning but it can also work your
glutes and hamstrings and really help
your posture and your balance so the
first thing you're going to do is rest
your forearms on the floor with your
elbows directly underneath your
shoulders and your hands facing forward
so that your arms are parallel extend
your legs out beneath you and rest your
toes in the floor your body should form
one straight line from your shoulders to
your heels
squeeze your entire core glutes quads
and tuck your butt under a little to
keep your lower back straight now make
sure you do not drop your hips
or raise your butt upwards towards the
ceiling keep things very very level and
you want to make sure that your head is
positioned so your neck is in a neutral
position and your focus is on your arms
now you're going to hold this position
for about 40 seconds now at first maybe
you can get to 20 seconds but you want
to work up to 40 seconds and you might
want to do this like two or maybe three
times
every other day all right so now that
you have a more comprehensive plan
for getting rid of that belly fat
you might want to check out this
tutorial on how to do keto in
intermittent fasting correctly